official introduction Peter you can
catch his new column the NFL column
football mun football morning's football
mornings I was gonna say football
morning in America
yeah but now morning in America every
Monday exclusively I know who thought of
that come you did know an King Oh your
wife did yeah we were sitting around
trying to think of a name for like about
three weeks after I signed with NBC yeah
and every name somebody hated we've
thought of 200 names and one day an King
says hey isn't is the Sunday night thing
called football night in America why'd
you call your column football morning in
America like it and I said to myself
Sam flood is going to like that name
we're gonna get some agreement on that
one right there I think and King
deserves a little cut of the kaiju to I
think she gets a little cut of the
collar no matter what all right
the topic right now in the NFL was what
oh look out
we got a spill in aisle six year old
bill I the topic I mean I guess
unfortunately is Terrell Owens or
Le'Veon Bell let me start with Terrell
go ahead do we know what is griping I
assume I mean look I I'm assuming that
it's the I got into my third year and
you know the way I look at that
basically is that two-thirds of the
three hundred and some-odd people who
were in the Pro Football Hall of Fame
got in after their first year of
eligibility
does that make Harry Carson and Ronnie
Arry and Lynn Swann and Fran Tarkenton
and do that does that make them less
Hall of Fame deserving does that make
their bus different no it's just this is
the silliest controversy in Hall of Fame
history but it's a controversy so we
must address it but also this is what he
wants I mean if he went there and just
said thank you I'm grateful and it's
great to join these these uh you know
fellow Hall of Famers you know there's
there's no I was out in Tahoe last week
at that golf tournament
Aaron Rogers out there but I was out
having a drink with a bunch of older
guys like people of Peter Kings
generation and one of them said to me
does he have any idea how for the rest
of his life I mean he's gonna be able to
make money off the whole thing now if he
disses the Hall of Fame is he going to
be able to make money off the Hall of
Fame and this was a this was a very
well-respected person and so I you know
the Hall of Fame sort of shuffles
business hall-of-famers ways I mean are
they gonna do that with Terrell Owens
now I don't know it's I that's not the
biggest reason or the biggest anything
but it just strikes me that he's cutting
off his nose to spite his face but
whatever should he have been a
first-ballot hall-of-famer
um I mean I've supported him all along I
didn't think it was some grave injustice
because I do think there were some
things against him nobody wants to hear
this but he was a turd of a teammate
that's all there is to it and he dropped
the ball a lot particularly later in his
career in my opinion though without any
question he deserves to be in the Pro
Football Hall of Fame I supported him
I'm glad he's in and I could care less
whether he's in Canon or not in Kim do
we view Randy Moss differently than we
do Terrell Owens I think we do because
Randy Moss to me I almost look at Randy
Moss is a singular player I don't look
at Terrell Owens is a singular player I
think Randy Moss was such an incredible
deep threat so incredibly great
stretching the field and dominating
games with his speed and his hands deep
downfield he had great hands I I mean I
look at Randy Moss as being 15% better
player whatever the numbers say them
Terrell Owens also he's grown up yeah he
has Randy Moss has really has yeah yeah
he's matured yeah and now Terrell Owens
wants to still make a comeback in the
CFL I read I just read that this is more
on my way up here I to each his own he
wants to do it I will say this few years
ago when I was running the mm QB we had
CFL week and I went up to two games in
the CFL and I met like three or four
coaches had long conversations John
Hufnagel remember him yeah he was a
either coach or GM of the Stampeders in
Calgary end state yeah he's a Penn State
guy anyway he's the former Giants
quarterback coach but anyway they all
all these coaches say all these guys
come up from the US and they say I can
just show up and be great it isn't that
way the field is different it's a more
one of the coaches told me it's a more
exhausting game you got to run more it's
a bigger field and so if you don't if
you're not in great shape if you don't
really want it you're not gonna be great
in Canada no matter who you are
yes Peter King is a new column football
morning in America every Monday morning
exclusively on NBC sports.com the
Le'Veon Bell situation how does this
turn into a positive for both dealers
and ladies I think it's a positive for
both if Le'Veon Bell shows up a training
camp basically says hey it didn't work
out life goes on I'm gonna have a great
year then I'm gonna go be a free agent
and make a lot of money and the Steelers
say good you gained 1,900 yards we go to
the AFC Championship game this is gonna
work out for everybody you make 14 and a
half million life is good
I say it'll be a bad thing if Le'Veon
Bell I think Adam Schefter reported the
other day that he may not show up that
he may have a hold out into the season
because he wants to be fresh and and and
and and a really good player for his
next team
you know I just I don't think that will
go well at all why is it the pay
structure for running backs hasn't
because nothing better because Dan I did
add a note in my column on Monday when I
was talking about DeMarco Murray the
last 10 NFL rushing champions
let's eliminate Adrian Peterson okay but
because he won three in the last ten
years the other seven rushing titles
have been won by seven different players
average draft slot 79 so you've got
DeMarco Murray you've got Kareem hunt
you've got Arian Foster who was not
drafted okay so you look at that and you
basically say okay Alvin Kamara rookie
Offensive Rookie of the Year last year
drafted somewhere in the 60s Kareem hunt
drafted 86 won the rushing title third
rookie to do it in 30 years and my whole
thing is you know you get running backs
down the line
why am I gonna commit borderline
quarterback money to a running back as
great as Le'Veon Bell is and I love
Le'Veon Bell but if I'm the Steelers I'm
thinking two things will get another
running back not maybe not as good as
Le'Veon Bell probably certainly not as
good but I hope cost one-fifth the
amount that Le'Veon Bell wanted and then
three years later when he gains a lot of
years we'll go get the next guy and and
look I don't mean that
running backs are are altogether totally
interchangeable but in recent years
running backs have basically become
interchangeable so based off of that the
Giants taking say Kwan Barclay I was
never not in favor I was never a big fan
of that
and it might work because if they play
their game that way and I think they
want to Eli Manning is gonna be 37 this
year they don't want to throw in 550
passes I'm sure I think they would
probably want to close to 50/50 run pass
ratio on that team so we'll see
and they are a different team a
different organization and Pat Shermer
Dave gentlemen they want to have not a
good running game but a great running
game so we'll see if it works
but is it cyclical because it yes like
the defense's you know got not smaller
like it was based on speed now because
you had it you had to cover these
receivers and get to the quarterback I
just felt like you know Jacksonville's
saying hey we can play great defense and
we got Leonard fournette let let's run
the football but yes it isn't
necessarily I don't look at Jacksonville
and say yep Leonard fournette arrived so
they became a great running team Doug
Marrone arrived and they became a great
running team
when Doug Marrone arrived even if they
had had TJ Yeldon and and Chris Ivory
they would have done exactly maybe they
would have run it I don't even know what
they ran it but 46% I don't even know
but they would have run it almost the
exact same okay so for net is great and
and he really helps them he motivates
them to run the ball more but wood with
Doug Marrone you were gonna do that
anyway speaking of Jackson Village
somebody tell me a couple of days ago
that shod cons end game is gonna be four
games in Jacksonville four games in
London so five years down the road at at
max you're gonna have four home games in
London for in Jacksonville would not
surprise me at all my feeling is that
the NFL is going is careening headlong
into having a team and and maybe
eventually more than one in Europe and I
think it could be by 2022 if you think
of it this way then there's gonna be a
new collective bargaining agreement
unless there's a strike in 2021 part of
that collective bargaining agreement is
going to be players giving their
permission
working out some deal may be increased
salary for all players who agree to play
in London I don't know but they're gonna
reach some deal in 2021 that the players
would agree that a cot that a team could
be relocated a team or teams I do not
think it's going to be more
than 32 teams in the NFL even if they
put a team in London but I think that is
an interesting solution I don't think
the people in Jacksonville would take it
well obviously and I'm not sure the
people in London would take it well
either I just don't I don't see how
people in London are gonna say hey let's
share a franchise with Jacksonville it
it I'm not saying it's unworkable its
clunky the Aaron Rodgers contract
situation you said you spent time with
him in in Tahoe I'm sure that came up oh
yeah I wrote about it on Monday I wrote
about it at length my feeling is that
that some quarterback D and the problem
is Aaron Rodgers gonna make an average
of 21 million over the next two years
you got Matt Ryan at 30
you got Kirk Cousins at 28 so if you
look at the way the quarterback
contracts usually work okay so Aaron
Rodgers signed a new deal average a 33
million a year for six years and that's
it he rides off into the sunset whatever
well you know two years after he signs
that he's gonna be the 8th highest-paid
quarterback and he say oh my god there
won't be 8 players making more than 30
through me it's monopoly money it
doesn't matter what the number is people
will spend to the cap they're gonna pay
the quarterback sixteen seventeen
percent of the cap and they'll do that
Aaron Rodgers when I talked to him about
this you could tell he was intrigued and
he just doesn't want to give anything
away right now but I believe Aaron
Rodgers and his agent David Dunn want to
be the first ones to basically say we
want to tie annual salary increases to
the salary cap to the increase in the
salary cap and we'll see if that works I
know the owners definitely don't want to
do that obviously but the most
interesting thing was Dan when I sat
when Aaron Rodgers he's different Aaron
Rodgers and I'm not saying that I'm not
close to Aaron Rodgers at at all okay
but he was different I'll tell you what
I mean
he went hey this is weird he went to see
the Dalai Lama in April and he spent an
hour and a half with the Dalai Lama and
all I can say as I walked out of there
and somebody said hey how was Rogers and
I said this sounds weird he was then he
really was said the dalai lama know who
aaron rodgers way i asked him that he
goes no I don't think so but he brought
him a football and a Packers cap and the
dalai lama put it on his facebook page
that was fantastic
but but Rogers Rogers was just so he was
just peaceful and I that's why and look
he realizes because my whole theory
about aaron rodgers turns 35 this year i
said my whole theory is you're not gonna
be like brady you're not gonna be like
breeze you don't want to play to your 45
and he acknowledged that to me he said
i'd like to play the line 40 but play
the way i'm playing now to have the kind
of athleticism to be able to move around
in the pocket the way i do now i don't
want to be a broken-down guy at age 40
so i think if he could play that way up
to age 40 that would give him six more
seasons in the NFL then he'd walk into
the sunset but isn't it interesting that
we look at tom brady and say it's best
quarterback best quarterback of all time
but the best quarterback is aaron
rodgers right well bye bye if you if you
look at the I think you just had a
Donald Trump
blackout moment in here if you look at
the way the system really works and not
only stats I think you would say okay
Aaron Rodgers is has the has the highest
quarterback rating well I mean he's got
an 11 point higher quarterback rating
than Joe Montana in history he's like 6
points higher than Brady and so but but
then again he doesn't have 8 Super Bowls
you know so you know who knows who's the
best quarterback of all time there's
different metrics why do you why is it
we hold it against LeBron that he lost
all those NBA Finals but we don't hold
it against Brady that he lost those
Super Bowl well because I think I think
because Brady's won 5 you know I think I
think
because you know and Chris Russo we
getting this argument all the time he
thinks he got to say Montana's the best
because he never lost a Super Bowl I
said and I've always thought this way
ask Joe Montana if he'd rather be 5 and
3 in Super Bowls or for a knowin Super
Bowls well I bet he'd rather be 5 and 3
didn't we ask Joe Montana that did you
what did he say he said yeah I talked
about Brady's losses and he goes I don't
know what that feelings like I never
lost one yeah so it doesn't sound like
Joe when you ask him yeah 8 would he
rather have gone to the Super Bowl eight
times and won five I think this was sick
or would he have rather gone four times
in one for I think he he see if you can
find it to be fair but it's a couple
years ago when the Super Bowl was in New
York and I yeah about that yeah and he I
can't imagine that anybody would rather
have been to four and be undefeated
versus going to eight would you rather I
have Jordan's six and no losses or go to
as many finals as LeBron but what's
LeBrons regularly in the final three and
three in front of six three yeah I I
don't know I I never I don't think we
give enough credibility credence to
getting there like LeBron totally you
got to eat straight NBA Finals that's
ridiculous but we don't we look at that
as a negative because I would never look
at it as a negative and I would never
look at I think you know I sit in that
Hall of Fame room I've sat there for 26
years I always just think to myself and
then look I'm one of 48 voters so I I
mean no more than anybody else in the
room but I always chafe when people
start emphasizing and talking about the
playoffs and the Super Bowls and
everything
well not Tommy nobis Tommy nobis was on
a horse crap Atlanta Falcons team and
what might have been 98 percent the
player the Dick Butkus was we you know
we don't really know but you know he was
on crappy teams and and that's the thing
that bothers me sometimes about the way
we consider does anybody say Ted
Williams was less of a hitter because he
never won a World Series no pee
we'll talk about Ted Williams like he
was the best hitter of all time all
right I got one more question before I
let you go why is it I feel like the
Chargers are gonna have a better season
than the Rams oh I think they could and
I think those two division this is the
first time in Dan maybe ever since I've
covered the league and I've covered the
league since 1984 I was thinking about
this the other day I'm gonna write some
about this for Monday probably the first
time that I think that the balance of
power absolutely unequivocally could be
out west in both divisions because now
look at the greatest new rivalry in the
NFL 49ers Rams Shanahan mcveigh
Garoppolo golf it's gonna be tremendous
fun out in the NFC West that's number
one and number two now I agree with you
about the charges I think the charges
are interesting I really think they're
gonna miss hunter oh that's that's that
is a that's as big an injury now since
the season ended last year now when
we're not talking Carson Wentz cuz I was
during the season but that is this big
an injury as there could be in the NFL
so but I agree with you and getting
Williams back the receiver having a
great wide receiver core I having a
great running back having a good not
great offensive line
I like the Chargers a lot I loved Irwin
James I was a great pick for them his
Phillip Rivers a quarter a Hall of Fame
quarterback now he he's he's right on to
more big big years but let's say
probably he probably is you know
probably is but Dan then you get into
the thing whether you say are we gonna
put in I was thinking about this the
other day are we gonna put in eight
quarterbacks from this era because we
could talk about eight quarterbacks from
this era
okay so we're very arguable Brady Ben
Rogers Brees
is stafford a whole thing no he's got to
do a lot more but I'm what I'm talking
about I'm talking about all of the guys
who are playing right now so what I'm
talking about is I don't know which one
of the let's say Garoppolo type I um you
know I look at Garoppolo right now and
obviously somebody might say hey you got
to draw a line of demarcation he's the
next generation and maybe you would say
that but I'm saying that in 2016 17 18
19 this era of football
there could be eight quarterbacks
because the passing game is so great and
so dominant and so unstoppable what do
you do with Eli Manning what are you
using all of him well okay so you know
and what do you do
you probably don't put Tony Romo in but
no Russian Russell Wilson I'd yeah
Russell Wilson so you've got all of
these guys you've got you got a lot of
potential Hall of Famers he's Peter King
is a new column it's a football
morning in America every Monday morning
thanks to his wife Ann King NBC
sports.com
is she your ghostwriter yes she sits
there every Monday night I sit there
having a glass of Cabernet and and she
does it all oh man Pete you work hard on
that column man yeah they work hard on
that column Congrats
okay success for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]